foreign
anyway so first of all good to see that
there's still a full house pretty much
for uh the final Talk of the day uh
before the drinks so my name is bus
indeed and I'm going to talk about how
we do ranking in online grocery and no
point for guessing Which online grocery
that's going to be about
so just to start with a bit of
audience participation who actually
knows about picnic
yeah that's pretty much everyone great
and we actually order for picnic well
still quite a
good score nice
uh so for people who are not quite
familiar
um I will start with a bit of a
corporate introduction
uh a mission statements making grocery
shopping simple fun and affordable for
everyone of course it sounds very
corporate but it does capture the basic
Basics pretty well
so this is more or less what it looks
like first of all we have mobile apps of
course in Android as well as iOS
um it's an only Supermarket so you can
choose all the groceries that you want
to want to buy
um obviously we have quite a large
assortment something like 8 000 products
so you can't show all of them at the
same time so we need to make some kind
of smart selection of products that we
want to show
this gets delivered to your doorstep
we promise and also deliver in a very
narrow time window so something like 20
minutes so I don't need to stay at home
the entire day for your delivery to
arrive
we have low prices no delivery fees
uh and also this is done in a
sustainable way so you don't need to
drive to the supermarket but we actually
deliver to your doorstep and we do this
in this nice electrical vehicles that
you probably have seen around
so that's more or less the overview of
what we do at picnic
um and that's more of the general
backgrounds now I want to go into the
more technical aspects
so I'm going to talk about ranking so
first of all I want to tell a bit more
about the app what it looks like and uh
how reckon place a role in different
parts of that
didn't want to go into two specific use
cases which are very important in
grocery shopping one is repurchasing
and the element is search
and then I want to wrap up
in the end
so first of all let's go into the
picking app in a bit more detail I
already told you it's essentially a
supermarket on your phone you can select
all the products that you want
purchase
well I think you need 35 years at least
and then we will deliver it to your home
for free
uh but as I mentioned there's lots of
products and only a limited space that
we can use in the app to show you
products so we need to be smart in what
are we actually going to show you
first of all let's just contrast it with
traditional supermarkets so if you think
about your typical offline supermarkets
everything is in shelves
and there's all kinds of opportunities
that are not available for offline
supermarkets but things that we can do
because being online
first of all it can be personalized so
we can actually show different people
different products which might be
relevant to them
um
it's searchable well I think search is a
very obvious functionality you can
search for coffee or beer or chips or
whatever and we will show you relevant
products
um so really the growth has come to you
instead of you having to go all the way
through the supermarket to find what you
want
and also it's potentially responsive so
we can interact with with you depending
on what you actually do in the app so we
can show more information we can show
you related products we can show you
recipes including that ingredients and
it gives us all kinds of new
opportunities to do clever stuff
so in this talk I want to focus on a few
parts of the app which are particularly
important
so when is the purchases page so if you
think a bit about your own grocery
shopping
if you go to the operating or whatever
what are you going to purchase
quite a lot of products are actually
stuff that you've bought before at some
point
and that's also the idea of this page it
collects all the articles that you've
bought with us before
um however this quickly adds up so for
many customers this is hundreds of
Articles so again here you need to be
clever in what articles are actually
going to show in The Limited space that
you have
and this is really about repurchasing
the other base I want to focus on is
search again searches a common
functionality
you enter certain search query you get a
bunch of products which are related to
that
uh
and there's actually a few different
kinds of relevance that come into play
there so one is what kind of products
are relevant to you as a customer
but also what is actually a good match
to the individual search term that you
use
and these two might
be similar but actually they are not
necessarily and also there might be
other business considerations where we
want to push certain products higher up
on the page or not
what I want you to take away from this
slide
is that we have different pages within
the app which have different
functionalities and it also means we
have different banking logic that we
need to serve to these different spots
and how to actually serve that so use
different ranking logic in different
places
it's actually quite conceptually
straightforward we just have a kind of
Json which is a ranking template
and directing temperatures actually yeah
like I said conceptually easy it of
course has a few labels like an ID and a
name and all that
but the interesting part are these two
so we have the triggers which tells you
in what cases do we actually activate
this kind of ranking logic
and we have to score a distribution
so this gives us the option of selecting
a few types of ranking logic giving them
some weights and then combining them
into one final score
um conceptually
makes a lot of sense it's quite easy
uh but of course it's also very useful
when talking to the business because
they can very easily understand what
produces a certain ranking on a certain
page what are the contributions to that
and it's even tunable by them if for
whatever reason they want to make
changes in that
so to give an example of what these
triggers and these score distributions
could look like
so there are also jsons for example it
could be activated for
if people search and end up on the
search page and use a specific search
term like olives for example
uh in that case we will serve a score
distribution which is a linear
combination of two rankers with some
logic behind it with different weights
and that way we can really tune the
individual ranking logic in different
parts of the app
so now I want to go into what are these
rankers actually what is the logic
behind rankers in different parts of the
app
so first let's focus on rebuying
so again the purchase page is the main
part of the app where this is
facilitated
so to recap it collects all your
articles that you've bought before
this is often tens to hundreds of
articles
people don't really like scrolling you
probably don't either so people tend to
convert pretty well from the top of the
page but not so much if they have to
scroll all the way down
so what do we do we need to rank
in a way that makes sense so people that
yeah if you're likely to convert for a
certain article
then it probably should be somewhere at
the top and the ones that you're
unlikely to buy in your next delivery
should be all the way to the bottom
so what we do is we rank on predicted
next basket repurchase probability I
want to yeah I will go into a bit more
detail later on
so this is supposed to be an animation
but it's not so just imagine it's
hilarious but let's go on
um what we have as a model is something
that we call carp internally hence also
the picture
it's sent for customer article readback
prediction and that's really I think
summarize is what it does
on an individual customer level and for
each article
we want to calculate s-core How likely
is the customer
to rebuy it in the next delivery
um so there's of course some standard
data stuff happening before the features
so we have we look at historical
deliveries we make a train split and
test splits and all that kind of stuff
but the interesting part happens
afterwards so if we look into the
features
of course the purchase history of the
customer is an important feature right
uh we can add all kinds of article
properties customer properties
Etc we need to take care of seasonality
and unavailability
but I really want to focus a bit more on
what we call product purchase
periodicity and that's really about
rebuying intervals rebank patterns for
articles
so just to illustrate in a cartoon how
this looks like so we have
purchasing for a few customers and two
products so we have bananas at the top
bananas is one of those products that
sell a lot and people can
well often rewrite quite often so you
can see that as well in these past
deliveries of these a few customers
and um if yeah if you contrast that to
shampoo for example at the bottom this
gets rebought far less frequently
so what you can do is you look at these
rebound intervals so
if you buy it now what's the next time
that you will rewrite again and then
look at the distribution of that kind of
quantities
so if you do that for bananas for
example and you average over all
customers that we buy bananas
you'll see that on average for example
they will rebuy it every one and a half
deliveries
for shampoo this will be a much larger
number
and that's already an important feature
in our modeling just an article level
measure of How likely people are are to
well at what intervals they'll actually
rebuy it
of course you can also do this at a
customer level which gives you even more
information some people might re-buy
these products very often others less so
um and you can imagine that if you
combine this with purchase history this
actually gives you a good indication
what's likely to be rebought and what's
not
so for an actual customer this looks
something like this
so this is for a type of milk
horizontally we have the weak number for
all delivery well yeah all weeks in 2022
and the weekday vertically so Monday to
Sunday
so the light blue squares means that
there was no delivery at all
on the light blue square for dark blue
squares the customer had a delivery with
this type of milk in it
and for the red squares they did buy a
similar type of milk
but not quite that article but something
similar
but I would like you to take away from
this picture are a few things
of course there's quite a bit of article
loyalty in
repurchasing
however customers can switch to related
products either intermittently or
permanently and this needs to be
reflected in the features as well so we
don't only look at article repurchasing
but also category level repurchasing
and finally if you look at kind of
weekdays this customer likes to order in
there's quite a lot of structure in that
as well customers tend to prefer the
same weekdays even though it's not the
same weekday all the time but it's
definitely a preference for early days
for example and this is also something
we can see in the next slide
so this is more of a
sciency slide we look at the
distribution of these rebuying intervals
in time
so what we really see here
so we look at again milk and we look at
laundry detergent which is something
that you don't tend to re-buy every week
and you see when you see Peaks here at
seven days 14 days and 21 days Etc and
that's really this weekly rebound
pattern where customers tend to prefer
to order on the same weekdays
the second thing I would like to take
away from this is that the shapes
actually look quite different from
something that you buy very often like
milk
and I see a very quick Decay lots of
rebuying after one week but relatively
speaking far less for the weeks after
for detergent is actually much more of a
long tail people don't have to re-bite
one week later but it can be three weeks
five weeks Ten Weeks Later quite easily
um
this is actually more or less the same
data but now we actually look at rank
so simply the first delivery second
delivery for delivery Etc
instead of uh look at it looking at it
in days
and we have a logarithmic axis
vertically
and this uh shows you two things
one is that if you only look at
sequences you actually lose a lot of
information so you lose this temporal
structure that you clearly see if you
look at real timestamps
and secondly uh it's even more obvious
here that there's actually a long tail
for repurchasing
and that also means that if you actually
want to aggregate this into one number
you probably shouldn't look at averages
but a median is much more appropriate
so in summary for this kind of feature
you want to use both temporal and
rank-based quantities
it's heavy tail so probably you should
use medians for these kind of quantities
and also mostly from the previous
picture
not only article repurchasing is
important but also category level
so there's more or less added here to
the features part
so for the model part as I already told
you it's more or less binary
classification that we as we do we want
to see is this article bought in the
next delivery or not
uh in practice we actually use this yeah
the probability score of How likely that
label is
as a measure of the conversion
probability
and it turns out it actually boosts what
classic models actually works pretty
well
and compared to the other multiple tried
it's the best performing one
so how do we evaluate this
in the end we make a ranking out of this
so actually order is important
domain we of course also look at other
metrics but the main metric that we
actually focus on
is something that's rank sensitive the
mean average Precision at 30. and the 30
is related to the fact that the purchase
page shows 30 products individually
in our implementation
more technical notes
we've checked that this model is well
calibrated so actually the class
probability is uh pretty much the same
thing as the conversion probability and
it makes interpretation quite easy also
for the business
and of course it's not just some kind of
theoretical model we actually need to
know that this works in practice
so if a b tested this extensively and it
actually works a lot better we have
increasing conversion and also people
tend to add from higher up in the page
as compared to previous logic
all right so that was my section on
repurchasing now let's go to search so
I've already mentioned search a bit
so the subtitle here is relevance in
various guises
what I mean by that is that there's
different ways of relevance that play a
role here so when is this repurchasing
uh Behavior which tells you a bit about
how relevant is this article to a
customer
but also we have
irrelevant to
um yeah between the search term and the
article how good it matches that
first let's go into what what happens in
search within the app
so I would actually
happens on the back end
so let's say we search for cheese
so what happens is that you enter it
into the app and then it gets sent
to a service called elasticsearch
and what happens in electric search is
actually that it tries to match the
search query cache
to all kinds of
uh article properties things like the
article name things like the supplier
name category name Etc
it gives a certain matching score and in
the end we end up with a certain set of
cheese related articles
and then we need to rank this in some in
some way right and of course we use
these ranking templates to actually do
that so we have a bunch of scores that
we uh that we use and we need to Define
what kind of weights do we give to each
of them
and that of course will result in a
final
result set we see a bunch of cheeses and
I think for cheese you will have tons of
results easily probably 100.
and this is ranked in a certain way
and of course the question is in what
way
so let's focus a bit on these ranking
templates but
as you can see I have free icon stare
and a three different types of ranking
logic that we might want to use
so the bottom one is one that I've
already discussed so that's really this
customer level rebound probability
the second is
some kind of boosting factor and this is
intentionally very generic but it's some
kind of
reason why the business would want to
push up certain articles this could be
because we have lots of stock of a
certain article this could be because uh
it's a new brand that we want to push up
higher up in the results but for
whatever reason we want to push this up
into the ranking
and the final one is the search term
article relevance and I want to spend a
minute or two explaining that but it's
really a measure of how well does the
search term and the article match
so of course this is related to search
conversion
but it's not quite as trivi as that
so if you look at search conversion uh
there's a complicating Factor called
position bias and I think most of you
will have heard of position bias
uh but it's also quite intuitive so if
you look on Google for example and you
search for something
um
people tend to click very much on the
top results they don't want to scroll
all the way down and definitely not to
page two or page three
they look at some they click on
something that looks kind of relevant
and is in an easy to reach position
this goes both for inspection so people
tend to inspect mostly the top results
but also simply the fact that it's rated
on top already gives people a bit of um
yeah more trust in the relevance of that
article
um and this also happens in search
conversion at picnic as well if you put
an article on top it's more likely to
get converted than if you put it further
down even though it might be more
relevant
so as from a physicist I put a nice
formula at the top right
um
and this is more or less
How likely is a customer to convert for
a certain search query for certain
documents which is equivalent to an
article in our case
at a certain position
so we decomposed into two factors
so at the top right for this R is the
relevance and that's really the first
thing article relevance that I'm talking
about
and that's really how relevant is this
article to the actual search term
however this gets weighted by the
position bias
so the position bias is normalized in
the sense that
we set the relevance for the article in
position one to one
and then it goes down
which basically means that if you put it
instead of the first part in the second
spot it will get only something like 62
percent of the conversion and a further
down you put it even though the
relevance doesn't change the conversion
will change
um so what we actually have is a
systematic way of calculating or at
least estimating this position bias
and calculating a d biased relevance
between search term and the article so
it's the star score
um so those are the three ingredients
that they want to talk about and then of
course we want to make sure artists want
to try to predict these different
weights in this ranking template to find
the optimal uh the optimal ranking
of course optimal again is not really a
very well defined term again there's a
balance between different relevances
and also from the business side there
might be other
um things at play so that's a boost
Vector that I want that just introduced
we might want to push up certain
articles because of profitability or
because of availability or whatever
so um we've actually set up something
conceptually similar to what I talked
about before
so we estimate a relevant score but now
not just on a customer article level but
also for individual Search terms
um and that's again based looking at
past deliveries and see what gets
conferred and what not
and then we can actually calculate
what's the expected value of this boost
that we have
so again we have
um yeah
to make sure this actually the expected
value for the boost for a certain
ranking of Articles so for a combination
for each article in a certain position
and then we can calculate what's the
expected value of this boost quantity
so again we have a relevance which is
dependent on
search query and the article
and we have the position bias that we
need to correct for and together this
gives you a conversion probability
and then we just use that as a weighing
Factor for the Boost
and that way we can actually find
for what
ranking so what combination of Articles
and positions we actually get the
highest value of the Boost
um
you could of course think well why not
use that directly
into the app there's a very technical
reason for that which is simply this is
a lot of data so we have lots of
customers lots of Articles lots of
Search terms so that data quantity kind
of explodes and that's why that's why we
actually approximate this
uh by again a linear combination of this
course that we already had and of course
that also gives you the benefit of this
explainability that we had before
so what we do is we simply do
um
yeah numerical calculation we look at
what are the what's the best combination
of these three scores so the star score
the carb score and this boost that gives
you the same kind of ranking as
well whatever gives you the best boost
sector
of course we've also tried this out in
practice
it's kind of ongoing still but still
initial results look quite good of
course I've removed all the actual
numbers but I think the overall idea is
still quite clear so we have two
baselines which is the
two left most ones
and it's rankings purely on carp or
purely on Star so only on certain
article relevant or only on personal
preference
then in light peripheral we have the
current business rankings and these are
really inspired by what uh is according
to the business analyst what's the best
combination that we should show for a
certain search term
and we see that indeed we structurally
outperform all these baselines and
actual production
uh rankings that are used so both in mrr
and NCG which are the metrics that we
look at
so um this is a pretty good way I think
of making sure that we
can balance this boost vector and actual
relevance to the customer in some
optimized way
all right that brings me to the summary
so first of all online grocery allows
for new ranking opportunities which I
think is obvious but good to State
explicitly
relevance is something that's different
between different pages and it might
also be different
between customer relevance and Company
relevance as well for example
the ranking templates is an easy and uh
easy and explainable way to mix and
match ranking logic in different parts
of the app
next basket prediction so carp and also
d by search relevance star are both
crucial ingredients in making these
rankings
and still a bit of work in progress but
uh
it's certainly feasible to optimize
these search templates structurally
and with that I would like to finish
with this obligatory comp company slides
of course where I have to thank lots of
people and we have vacancies as well and
with that I would like to thank you as
well and happy to take any questions
thanks for the very interesting talk bus
any questions
mainly let me start
thank you hi I'm not a user of the app
myself so it might be an obvious there
might be an obvious answer from other
users but um I was wondering whether you
also do like real-time updates in the
sense that a ranking updates in sense
that when I select my pasta the cheese
comes up Etc because you've been talking
about basket updates but how about that
very good question actually we do not
systematically
um and the problem is really more
technical this is all updated in batch
actually so every morning this gets
recalculated
um but doing this on a real-time basis
is
most technical research is not
implemented yet but it's a work in
progress that we are working on uh
there's also an additional reason
uh which is that there is actually some
value instability in ranking uh if you
use the app so you don't want to reopen
the app and then suddenly your ranking
gets all uh
gets updated for simply because there's
been a rerun in the meantime
yes
really cool talk happy to see
elasticsearch is being used still
um what type of products do you struggle
the most with like new products
um
it's a good question actually so uh
seasonal products is a difficult one so
what happens sometimes with paper note
for example is that they are in season
four two months whatever
then they get out of Assortment all of a
sudden and then at some point in October
or whatever September I don't know they
are informant again and then you
actually want to show them but if you're
not careful you're actually push them
all the way down because they haven't
been rebuilt for a long period
so I think seasonal articles is a big
one
and relates to that is
if there's been systematic
unavailability so as you might know
there have been some supplier issues all
over the country with certain brands
there's also something that pollutes
your data because it looks like
customers don't want to buy something
but they actually they couldn't buy it
so I think those are the two main
problematic cases
aren't paper noted like half a year by
now yeah probably
auspicious whatever
do you adjust for uh holidays and such
um
not so much in ranking actually no
we do of course have all kinds of
holiday Corrections in forecasting and
product purchases etc for ranking not so
much now
but of course there's uh
because these templates we can actually
have the business Define boosting
factors and they do that for certain
seasonal products for example
but that's more of manual process
thank you so much yeah welcome
hi I was wondering how do you deal with
the cold start products
um yeah so for carpets actually uh
easy in the sense that we focus
electricity on rebuying
so there's no cold certain sensors if
it's included you have bought it at
least once
um but of course it only gets reliable
once you've rebuilt it once sorry yeah
if you've rebuild it once so I bought it
twice until so then at least we have
some kind of estimate of
what is the rebuying interval that is
relevant to you so to do is we have
fallbacks to this article level rebound
intervals that is our best guess for uh
for you if you're falling bullet once
the question and I
hi uh so as per the recommendations I
feel it's more like content based
recommendations so do you take into
consideration collaborative
recommendations as well by looking at
what people from a region are ordering
or is it more like always what did you
buy the previous time yeah so this is
very much content based so it's
personalized but only at an article
level
so there's no collaboration effects in
here there's actually something that's
actually being investigated at the
moment to also get these more article
interactions
into the recommendations as well